[Musica]
buon pomeriggio a tutti parlare può
sembrare una cosa facile
è un po come respirare sì è vero ci
sembra facile può venirci automatico il
più delle volte avviene al di fuori
della nostra consapevolezza parlare è
così scontato che spesso non ci rendiamo
conto dell'importanza che riveste nella
vita di ogni giorno
eppure le parole che scegliamo e come le
intoniamo insieme al linguaggio del
corpo al contatto visivo sono il nostro
biglietto da visita con gli altri il
modo in cui ci presentiamo e come ci
poniamo in situazioni quali conoscere
persone nuove o inserisce in un nuovo
ambiente contribuiscono a formare la
prima impressione che l'altro si fa di
noi
ecco perché parlare non implica
solamente comunicare un contenuto
veicolare un messaggio ma ad un livello
più profondo e più intimo esprime chi
siamo
parlare è una cosa facile
o almeno può sembrarlo a voi ma non per
tutti è così
immaginate di avere un concetto in testa
e di volerlo esprimere
facile no tutto è chiaro nella vostra
mente quali vocaboli utilizzare che in
fasi dare al discorso quando fare delle
pause strategiche per catturare
l'attenzione di chi vi ascolta il
messaggio è pronto probabilmente avete
ponderato bene ogni singola parola e
nella vostra mente suona bellissimo
perfetto ma e qui c'è un ma
sentite che non riuscirete a dirlo e lo
sapete ancora prima di provarci
avvertite un blocco qua nell'addome
l'aria dai polmoni non arriva fino alla
bocca labbra e lingua non rispondono più
ai vostri comandi
ma rimangono come paralizzate in una
posizione e non si smuovono da lì e
immaginatevi ancora che che questa
situazione non accada ogni tanto ma vh
da ogni volta che ordinate un caffè al
bar
ogni volta che dite pronto al telefono
ogni volta che vi presentate con
qualcuno
ecco questo è ciò che succede quando si
balbetta black out totale
pensate che la balbuzie sia solo mi
chiamo valentina assolutamente no
la balbuzie non compromettere soltanto
l'esposizione la forma con cui un
messaggio viene espresso ma e molte
situazioni ne condiziona proprio il
contenuto e quando il blocco della
parola si fa insuperabile oltre alla
tensione fisica che può tradursi in
spasm in teak facciali chi balbetta cosa
fa
continua a riformulare il proprio
pensiero lo cambia più e più volte
perché è quello che è in testa come lo
ha in testa non riuscirà a dirlo è come
quando siete in macchina il radio
mandano la vostra canzone preferita e
sul più bello è entrata in una lunga
galleria magari all'inizio
all'interferenza è sopportabile riuscite
ancora a seguire il ritmo della canzone
poi tutto un tratto il segnale non
prende più e sentite solo quel
gracchiare fastidioso di primo acchito
voi non è che vivi da te per vinti
magari smanettate con le frequenze
hearts più hearts meno per
risintonizzare la stazione radio
eppure è niente non prende non c'è
niente da fare
ancora non vi arrendete allora dice
vabbè provo a cambiare trasmissione e
provo ad ascoltare qualcos'altro ma
ovunque vispo stiate ormai c'è solo quel
gracchiare fastidioso la vostra canzone
non c'è più e in ogni caso che aspettate
di uscire dalla galleria o che a furia
di cambiare troviate un altro debole
segnale
la canzone che tanto volevate ascoltare
ormai ve la siete persa con la balbuzie
accade un po la stessa cosa
e qual è il risultato oltre a non
riuscire a dire ciò che volete dire
quando lo volete dire né uscite
affaticati
io stessa mi sono ritrovata più volte a
fare discorsi anche molto distanti nel
contenuto da come li avevo pensati
ricorrevo a sinonimi giri di parole
intercalare ovvero tutte quelle parole o
breve espressioni usate come rincorsa
per raggirare un blocco è sì allora
appunto nel senso diciamo che in pratica
e sentivo che non potevo fare altrimenti
perché ero come in un campo minato in
cui le bombe erano le parole che non
uscivano e io dovevo fare di tutto per
per scansarle per non innescarle ma
questo non succedeva solo con le parole
scomode con il tempo ho iniziato via via
ad evitare anche diverse situazioni o a
pensarci molto bene prima di metterci la
faccia
vi faccio qualche esempio
da ragazzina a scuola l'ora di narrativa
e di lettura a voce alta per me erano
sempre l'occasione perfetta per correre
in bagno oppure il mio libro guarda caso
era sempre quello difettoso a cui
mancavano delle pagine perché perché io
poco prima del mio turno silenziosamente
strappavo dal libro di narrativa
la pagina che avrei dovuto leggere anche
anche le interrogazioni mi ricordo erano
un momento molto faticoso parlavo a
monosillabi con la voce strozzata spesso
fingevo degli attacchi di tokyo in
mischia arrivo continuamente la voce
quando sentivo che la parola che volevo
dire non sarebbe uscita
per non parlare poi delle università
prima di iscrivermi a psicologia cosa ho
fatto
ho studiato meticolosamente il piano di
studi contando ad uno ad uno
quanti esami orali ci fossero e se la
tesi altri né al triennio andasse
discusso o meno per fortuna no e nelle
rare occasioni in cui magari c'era un
lavoro di gruppo da esporre in aula
davanti a tutti io cosa facevo non il
giorno stesso ma qualche giorno prima mi
portavo avanti mi davo malata e poi
consegnavo la mia parte di lavoro via
mail così accadeva da studentesca è la
stessa cosa si stava ripetendo poi anche
nelle prime esperienze di lavoro nel mio
tirocinio post lauream ve la faccio
breve come vivevo la mia balbuzie
in una parola io mi nascondevo non ero
davvero protagonista della mia vita ma
la lasciavo scorrere vedevo la mia
balbuzie come una menomazione fisica
qualcosa che mi sarei tenuta per sempre
a cui doveva accettarla mi dovevo
arrendere
questo almeno fino a che nel 2013
ho avuto un incontro fortuito del tutto
casuale ma che mi ha cambiato la vita
ero alla fiera dell'artigianato con il
mio fidanzato e mi sono imbattuta in un
piccolo stand in cui spiccava un motto
quasi una provocazione diceva se queste
sono babbo e banane allora chiama c e io
ho subito pensato tra me e me oh mio dio
mi stanno cercando
e allora come prima reazione cosa ho
fatto
ho girato al largo e roero scossa
turbata non ho preso il coraggio subito
mi ci è voluto qualche giorno però poi
ci sono tornata ed è lì che ho
conosciuto giovanni muscarà un ex
balbuziente
fondatore di un centro per il
superamento della balbuzie una persona
completamente diversa da me io vedevo la
mia balbuzie come una condanna
lui aveva fatto della sua balbuzie un
opportunità di miglioramento di crescita
di affermazione a livello personale e
professionale
per me la balbuzie era un limite che mi
frenava per lui una risorsa che lo
spronava io vedevo la balbuzie come
insuperabile
lui invece mi parlava del metodo
riabilitativo che aveva ideato e del
percorso da intraprendere
mi ha colpito il suo sguardo perché
andava oltre i classici sintomi della
balbuzie il numero di sillabe ripetute i
blocchi prolungamenti di suoni ma
prendeva in esame la persona a 360 gradi
dagli aspetti i motori sottostanti la
produzione del linguaggio a quelli più
comportamentali psico emotivi legati al
mettersi in gioco nella propria
quotidianità quell'incontro ha come
riacceso in me la speranza di poter
davvero superare la mia fatica ma non
soltanto per parlare bene per parlare
meglio ma soprattutto per poter
esprimere me stessa al cento per cento e
poter così realizzare le mie ambizioni
miei desideri
ed è così che ho cominciato il mio
percorso è stata in prima battuta
un'esperienza di conoscenza conoscenza
del mio corpo e della mia motricità ho
imparato a prestare attenzione a
conoscere cosa succede nel mio corpo
quando parlo che movimenti fanno la mia
lingua le mie labbra la mia bandi bola
cosa succede nel mio addome
come cambia il mio respiro e
ho quindi capito che effettivamente
parlare non era poi una cosa tanto
semplice come pensavo fino a poco tempo
prima ma una funzione cognitiva
complessa in cui interagiscono sono
connesse più parti del nostro corpo più
aree del nostro cervello
ho imparato quindi a conoscere i miei
movimenti e a controllarli coordinandoli
al millimetro e ovviamente cosa più
importante di tutte
ho imparato a gestire il mio corpo e di
conseguenza la mia voce anche sotto
pressione proprio quando senti il blocco
lì dietro l'angolo
dalle situazioni apparentemente più
semplice ma spesso così difficili per
chi balbetta come
prendere un caffè al bar fare una
telefonata a fare una ricarica al
cellulare prendere un biglietto della
metro alle situazioni più complesse come
per esempio parlare in pubblico
sostenere un colloquio di lavoro
interagire durante un dibattito ho
acquisito un'abilità nuova che mi ha
permesso finalmente di trasmettere ciò
che avevo dentro con le parole che avevo
in testa e senza più doversi girare
intorno e questo questo senso di libertà
nel esprimermi mi ha portata a fare cose
che prima non avrei mai pensato di poter
fare vi faccio un esempio
anzi una breve carrellata marzo 2014
concludo il mio anno di tirocinio post
laurea anno presso una clinica a milano
un'esperienza intensa stimolante
positiva sotto molti aspetti ma che mi
fa ancora una volta a sbattere la testa
contro il peso della mia balbuzie perché
alcune attività io proprio non riuscivo
a farle aprile 2014 inizio il mio
percorso per la balbuzie con giovanni
moscara giugno 2014 quindi pochi mesi
dopo
sostengo l'esame di stato per prendere
l'abilitazione come psicologa iscrivermi
all'albo
c'è un esame orale e per la prima volta
a 26 anni riesco finalmente a parlare
bene davanti ad un intera commissione di
docenti
ma non è tutto settembre 2014 rientro
nella clinica dove avevo fatto il mio
tirocinio
stavolta non più come tirocinante ma
come è strutturata
ovviamente non è un gioco da ragazzi non
vi nascondo nelle prime settimane la
tensione era era era alle stelle non sto
a raccontarvi tutti i giorni le continue
corse lavanderia cambiare la divisa
tanto ero agitata tanto sentivo questa
pressione ma nonostante tutto questo
sono finalmente nelle condizioni di
poter fare il mio lavoro a tutti gli
effetti
interagisco con successo con i pazienti
con i miei colleghi nelle riunioni
d'equipe con i tirocinanti che via via
mi vengono affidati a cui devo insegnare
il lavoro e questo non lo sento questo
cambiamento non lo avverto soltanto a
lavoro ma anche fuori fuori mi sento più
sicura più libera nell'interagire con
gli altri sono più propositiva o più
sicurezza
banalmente non mi limito più a mandare
messaggi ma chiamo le persone guardo le
persone in faccia quando devo prendere
parola non sto a guardare un punto per
terra come il balbuziente medio di
solito fa quando sta parlando con
qualcuno
questo percorso penso che abbia
cresciuto non soltanto la mia fluenza la
mia capacità di parlare ma mi ha fatto
scoprire alcuni aspetti della mia
persona che io non pensavo di possedere
determinazione intraprendenza fertilità
tutte caratteristiche che probabilmente
io già avevo ma erano come ingabbiate
imprigionate dalla mia balbuzie e oggi
sto dall'altra parte perché il mio
lavoro consiste proprio nella aiutare
chi soffre di questa fatica a superarla
ea ritornare protagonista della propria
vita senza più limiti e barriere perché
non mi stancherò mai di dirlo la
balbuzie non è solo un problema di
linguaggio d'influenza ma intacca sulla
qualità della vita della persona ne
condiziona le relazioni le scelte le
decisioni le connessioni con le altre
persone
adesso posso dire con orgoglio di aver
fatto mio il messaggio di giovanni
muscarà ovvero che un limite davvero può
trasformarsi in un'opportunità ed è una
risorsa per cambiare per migliorarsi e
la soddisfazione per me è più grande è
quella di poter condividere con le
persone che aiuto i loro successi
raggiunti da quelli grandi a quelli più
piccoli che sia a scuola sia lavoro se
in famiglia perché attraverso le loro
conquiste
io sento di poter vivere anch'io tutte
quelle esperienze che magari non ho
potuto sperimentare in prima persona in
passato attraverso i loro traguardi io è
come se avessi una rivincita sui miei
traguardi mancati con qualche piccola
eccezione come per esempio adesso lo
stare di fronte a tutti voi su questo
palco oggi e potermi esprimere con la
forza della mia voce tutto il mondo che
ho dentro
grazie
[Applauso]